welcome friends
my name is grameet kohindi i go by gg
i'm a product manager in google
databases
product team today i'll be talking about
bare metal solutions
and how bmw solutions enable all our
enterprises
to bring all their workloads closer to
gcp
regardless if the workloads were written
for a cloud native environment or not
as you know most of our enterprises
that we work with are planning to move
to a public cloud
environment not only that gartner
surveyed a lot of these
enterprises and they came to a
conclusion that
80 percent of these enterprises will
move out of their own
operated data centers by 2025.
a lot of you are already in the journey
of moving out of your current
infrastructure
to a cloud based environment either
in a public cloud setting or in a
private cloud setting
what are the key migration and
modernization challenges that most of
our enterprise customers face
first and foremost owning and operating
the infrastructure
was a big differentiator for a lot of
the enterprises
20 years ago but given the advances that
we have in current silicon technology
whether it's compute or storage or
networking
the differentiation owning and operating
your infrastructure brings in
is fairly low to your business secondly
most enterprises want to embrace the
mythology of developing applications in
cloud
whether it would be agile development
models whether it would be absorbing new
technologies like
artificial intelligence and ml at a much
much quicker phase
or whether it be adapting a very
different way a devops different way
a driven way of running it
but where the complexity comes in is
how do you marry these two different
concepts
and this is where google cloud steps in
our goal is to meet you where you are to
be a
partner in creating a migration strategy
that lets you
run what you want where you want how you
want
take your investment in your current
assets
and gradually roll them out into the
best
available platform for them in a public
cloud
our goal here is to reduce your risk
reduce your costs
at the same time maintaining an agility
to bring
your mission-critical workloads as close
as to google cloud and modernize from
there on
we believe this to be a three-step
journey first
all the workflows that you run today
which are not written to run in the
cloud native environment
remove them as is by moving them as is
we reduce our risk it takes to come run
in near
a public cloud environment second
we also divert your investment in rather
retuning your application your existing
applications to run
the existing legacy applications to run
in
a public cloud environment rather taking
that investment to modernize those
applications to run natively in a public
cloud environment
third in this approach you we believe
not only you can
do this at a much reduced cost with a
much reduced
uh risk but at the same time we can
speed up
your journey to migration to cloud
and each application will have its own
unique journey
each application has its unique business
value to you as a customer
and we understand that and we are here
to support the unique journey per
application
some of them will lift and shift from on
premises and stay in cloud as is
some of them will have to modernize
before they can be lift and ship
some of them might have to be rewritten
in a cloud native format
google cloud provides option for all
these pads
with your business goals being central
to or in
in our minds let's see how bare metal
solutions
and uh play a role in solving these
problems
but before we go there let's define and
let's try to characterize what those
challenges are
first majority of your mission critical
applications
run on forward on databases
that were not natively written for cloud
same time they are the pieces of
applications that runs the core of your
business
have a very high impact on how your
business runs today second
they are really complex in their own
requirements
they have been written over the years
they have a good have a plethora of
combinations of
off-the-shelf apps and the apps that
were
within homegrown the apps that have
contributions for
decades by your engineers and other
engineers
so migrating such apps or retargeting
these and these apps
need careful attention and that's where
google cloud comes in
uh in addition some of these apps also
might have very stringent hardware
requirements the type of hardware
there the particular software vendors
will certify
and these apps will have to run on those
hardware and here also bare metal comes
in
and solves the problem by providing a
certified hardware to run your
applications
but what's the crux of this uh this this
challenge
is the interoperability of between your
various databases various
mid tiers where applications uh have
is also a challenge in many cases a lot
of our customers don't even have a full
view
of how intertwined their application
estate is with the database estate
we cannot modernize just one without
also paying careful
detailed attention to the other
this care kept in mind we develop bare
metal solutions
which provides you the best platform
to migrate all your legacy and complex
apps which are difficult to modernize
as close as to cloud and then on a
step-by-step
gradual manner take this applications
and migrate them and modernize them
in a cloud native environment wherever
it's possible
let's see what google bay metal
solutions offer you
the key text of
the context of diameter solutions is a
ability to offer
purpose-built hardware a lot of software
vendors
and a lot of operating system vendors
have restrictions on
the kind of hardware their applications
can run on the kind of hardware that
gives them the best maximum
performance for their databases of
applications
so what we have done is taken the latest
and the greatest the silicon industry
has to offer
marry it what what a certified soft
hardware list for these specialized
vendors would be and provide you in a
setting
in which is very close to gcp from a
latency standpoint
and you have all access to all your gcp
services
from this purpose-built hardware
solution and vice versa
so that you can move the data freely
between the two
at the same time your applications that
are running in one way or the other
do not see significant network the
latency difference between the two as
well
we wrap this around a google
managed billing and support services at
the same time you contract with google
for
all your bare metal needs google is the
only party you engage with
google in turn
in turn procures the latest and the
greatest the hardware industry has to
offer
and provides that in the bare metal
solution for you
but you might ask what happens to all
the investment that you have already
made your existing
database administrators themes system
administrator dreams
what happens to all this system
integrators you have been working on
over the
years you can bring them as is to this
environment
for most power reasons this environment
will look like a new hardware refresh to
what you're already doing
and you can pick and choose the pieces
of infrastructure that you need to
modernize
move to cloud native or keep them in
their map as your application needs
dictates
most techie air tech enthusiasts will
say
i will only believe this when i see
diagram so i wanted to walk you through
how the architecture looks like
and also open the possibilities of what
you can do with this architecture
and how you can bring in some of the
most complex workflows you run
to this architecture two aspects of this
on the right side what you see is a
region extension this is a dedicated
hardware hosting space which is
connected with a
low latency interconnected google cloud
every entity in google cloud is able to
access every entity in the region
extension
with latencies in most cases less than
one milliseconds
in in some cases less than two
milliseconds
from an application perspective or from
a database perspective of a military
perspective
this all is exist it sits in one large
networking construct
and every application have access to
every other
entity running in this extension
the three common design patterns that we
see first
is in some cases customers wants to run
their packaged apps
which only runs on certain certified
hardware directly on a bare metal server
second our customers have bring in their
database and keep their applications
in gcp and the database comes with their
own internal tooling
their own internal monitoring their own
internal
best practices they can bring the
internal tooling and the database as
is and run on the bare metal servers and
connect
seamlessly to the applications running
in gcp
the third design pattern we see the
customer just comes with the database
in such scenarios we provide an
automation toolpak which makes the
lifecycle of database managing a
database much easier
this automated toolpath is an open
source contribution from google you can
find that at github it's written in
ansible it automates tasks like
provisioning a database provisioning a
backup provisioning a standby database
and hence and so forth you can pick and
choose the amount of automation you need
you can modify this automation if you
want some
features to be added from us you can
request that and we can do that as well
net net we have uh the capability to
emulate any design pattern that you have
today
and bring it and run it in region
extensions for you
one key aspect of any database enviro
deployment
is storage and we use state-of-the-art
tier one storage i'll talk a little bit
more about what all we do for storage
and operating systems in this one
key aspect for any software that runs in
region extension
is this it follows the bring your own
license model
you have root access to the servers you
have root access to the database
you uh google has no visibility on what
kind of
applications you're running on the bare
metal servers
but we do make the user's life easier by
providing technologies like snapshots
so for example today you might be
running
red hat linux in one of the bare metal
server
and then you probably have a hundred
bare metal servers
and you probably want to patch them at
some point in time
since all these servers are disk class
and they all boot from a san
all you have to do is take a snapshot of
one of the golden images
and then roll it across your entire
fleet
using the same snapshot hence lowering
the amount of effort that you have to do
spend on managing an operating system
patch
across your fleet the same model can be
applied to
applications running on top of these
operating systems as well
let's talk about what google provides as
a service in this model
and what's our customer responsibility
here so
in a high level construct we manage
anything that has to do with the
hardware so
we provide uv facilities we provide the
power cooling we provide the physical
security we manage the network security
we make sure
all the break fix and smart hands is
handled by us for
you at the same time we also
tune the storage for best application
performance
we have worked with industry standard
vendors
or industry leading vendors we have
taken their best practices
combined with the best practices of all
the specialized software vendors
and implemented that in the bare metal
solution
so when we provision a storage for you
it has been auto-tuned for the next
performance
for that database or the application
that you're planning to run on top of it
it takes a big chunk of a of work that
needed to be do
needed to be done when you move from
on-premises to the club
again on being on the guiding principle
here
the migration to our service running in
cloud
our goal is to minimize your effort
required to do so so that you can take
that extra resources
in modernizing those applications
everything that runs in their mobile
environment
have access to all google services and
top of that
google takes care of support billing and
and hardware monitoring tools
let's talk about what's your
responsibility i touched about the os
configuration responsibility earlier
the same applies to application
installation configuration and
management
or automation tool pack helps it helps
in that area for some database
deployments and database management
and database backup in dr at the same
time
we are able to emulate some of the most
complex on-premises
networks in our written extension
which are plugged into the google
interconnect
so all your services appear as if
they're running in a giant network
construct
and they can be accessed across the
interconnect globally
second when it comes to management
we provide an sla driven service for
infrastructure
we managed everything that goes on with
the infrastructure
and anything that goes on with the
application is managed by our customers
you can work with google marketplace
tools to help that experience
that experience be more managed at the
same time you can use your own system
integrators
to have this experience more managed for
backup and recovery
we do provide local storage for
your instant restore backups at the same
time
the customers have full flexibility to
have snapshots for their databases and
applications as well
i'll talk about that in a few minutes
before we go discuss the details of what
shapes we provide and what storage shape
search properties we provide let's talk
about what your support experience will
be
this is a google first party service
google is responsible
for this support first level support of
what happens in the agent extension
google is responsible for bare metal
hardware your network your interconnect
your security whether it be physical
or be it network security
we take care of facilities we provide
you with smart hand support
at the same time we have a collaborative
support model with
some enterprise applications and all
operating system vendors
in which we help our customers triage
operating system issues
and application issues at the same time
this is a three
nines sla infrastructure sla
by google and we are accountable for
that
we also have solution guides that enable
database workloads that takes that three
nine slas and
implement a four nine and a five nine
service on top of that
in addition to this we also provide
consultative support
for application debugging
for example say your application or
database has a particular issue
and then you call google uh google
support for helping you out with issue a
consultative support team will look at
the issue and provide you guidance
what's the best logs you need to procure
what's the best the metrics you need to
procure so that you can work
actively with your own storage with your
own software provider
and get to a root cause sooner than
later it's a very unique
operating model that we have and we have
staff some of the
brightest support teams when it comes to
application support
in this regard now let's take a deep
look on what kind of bare metal servers
we provide
what's the storage flavors we offer and
how they all work together and where the
tuning happens
so two basic category two broad category
of servers
uh small and medium which we think will
be very useful for
uh single high performance apps at the
same time as
as dev test systems and at the same time
as cluster database systems of
large and extra large machines to enable
mission critical apps which have that
kind of demand from the infrastructure
one way we are very unique compared to
any other public cloud vendor
is we adapt the latest and the greatest
silicon technology
very soon it's released at the same time
we offer
full bare metal configurations with the
highest memory to core
density ratio why i'm talking about
memory to code density ratio
memory to core density ratio is very
important when you talk about
databases and applications the higher
the ratio the more databases and the
more applications you can run on the
same
server and that has an order of
magnitude impact
on the software licensing and software
support you have to pay for that server
not even to talk about the management
benefits you get for managing a fewer
amount of servers in a large monitor
service
today we have offered intel cascade link
servers
which are the latest that intel's office
today and we'll keep our
cadence as and when the new silicon
technologies come
on on them on the horizon one very
unique
offering to bare metal service solution
is a four socket hundred and twelve core
machines they offer
contiguous 3 terabyte memory probably
really for the most stringent database
or application
you have in your enterprise to be run
right next to google cloud with all the
cloud goodness
for applications what really matters for
the performance is how well the storage
performs
how well the storage handles linear
scalability
how well storage handles bottlenecks and
how well storage handles noisy neighbors
what we have done here has taken the
best practices of our tier one storage
vendor
and the best practices of most operating
systems and application
vendors and incorporated them in this
deployment model
so when you provision and all nvme based
storage in our environment
it's a linear uh performance model
as and then to add more storage you get
more
guaranteed or a short performance at a
very low latency
you can do hundreds and thousands of
iaps well below
one millisecond some things that
transactional databases really like
and some things that a lot of dba teams
struggle and invest a lot
to get that right level of tuning in
bare metal solutions we take
care of that for all of our customers
a second thing that's very important for
databases and applications is ability to
restore
your local backups quicker for that
we offer in this construct all disk
storage which is connected
within the region so you do not have to
go to
an object storage access as you might
have to do in other public clouds
which you can access really really
quickly in case of a
disaster or in case of any rollback
issues that you might have
all these storage offerings are
configured with
automated snapshots automated snapshots
are really helpful
for databases and application tests
there at the same time
they're very helpful for data protection
of the environment as well
our storage has full connectivity to gcs
that's google cloud storage you can move
backups from
all disks to cold here and near line
tier
in gcs and take full advantage or cost
advantage
of a public cloud storage uh platform in
that regard
you can also connect these database
and application servers to applications
running or analytics running
in google cloud in this case google
cloud analytics and google cloud will
have direct low latency access
to your transactional databases you can
run
ai ml models on top of your
transactional databases in real time to
make you
to help you make better decisions the
possibilities that you have with this
architecture are
endless we marry the best google cloud
has to offer
with the best silicon technology that
exists there
and make provide a very secure low
latency offering
all backed behind a google sla
all these servers that we use here are
disk class
they all boot from uh network of
network mounted storage their operating
systems are also hosted in the network
market storage
there is no data that is persistent
on these the servers
hence makes the lifecycle management of
the server very very efficient
at the same time the network between the
servers and the storage is configured by
us the network between the servers and
the gcp
is also configured by google the network
between the server and the application
tier
is also configured by uh by google
now let's take a how will this
architecture
actually look in real life and how will
your applications use this
i'm using a very simplistic construct
i'm sure your
workloads are much more complex than
this and
our teams will be happy to simplify that
your current architectures and
and marry them with our design patterns
what i'm showing here
is a trusted database running in the
region extension
which is getting replicated using
database native technology
to another region extension so within
the region extension the cluster
database provides you high availability
built on databases native capabilities
at the same time it uses the google's
networking
backbone to replicate to the next region
to another region and make sure you have
the right dr strategy in place
as well you can run your right heavy
transaction workloads on
one region extension and you can run
your read heavy
workloads on the other region extensions
again using all database native
technologies
in both these constructs you have full
access to a tool pack
which you can use to manage the storage
for the database install the database
configure the backup for the database
configure replication for the database
do things like patching pre-checks for
the database using the tool pack
or or integrate the tool back in your
existing
uh tooling as well at the same time the
applications running in
google cloud they for them the database
appears
as if it's on the other applications of
where it's running indian
extension appears as if they're running
within the google cloud construct
enabling seamless development of new
applications
along your on top of your business
critical data
at the same time uh allowing you a
chance to modernize your architecture at
a piece by piece level
and at a pace that makes the most sense
for your business
while controlling cost and managing risk
the next natural question would be hey
gg i heard a lot about this technology
how can i consume this
so today we are ga in five regions
globally
you we are available in frankfurt and
london in europe
we are available in los angeles and
virginia
in the us we are live in sydney
and in apac so we have a complete
truly global footprint and this
footprint is expanding
as we speak within this year we will
have
four more regions turned on one will be
in singapore
tokyo followed by netherlands and brazil
south hollow
develop with this with one thing in mind
to meet our customers where they are
whether it is their migration journey
whether it's their modernization journey
whether it's an ability to lift and
shift their workloads
or or whether it be the region which
they are most
active or most prevalent
with that being said thank you for
taking the time
and listening to your talk it's it's
always great to bring the latest
innovation that we are
creating in gcp and sharing it with our
customers
so thank you for your time and i'll look
forward to talking to you soon